[Musik]
privat und etwas elitär die zeppelin
universität am bodensee wer hier
studiert zahlt 4000 euro pro semester
und will nach oben
ihr weg aber ist ein anderer
für mich ist karriere zu geben also das
beste was ich hab zu geben das heißt ich
muss erst mal rausfinden was ist
eigentlich das fest in mir ich gehe
nicht dahin wo das geld ist so und
verbiegt mich quasi dafür sondern nicht
rückhaltlos meine leidenschaft los auch
mein ruf werde ich gebraucht und ich
habe ein ganz starkes vertrauen ist das
geld kommt und es kommt auch also es ist
ganz schön leicht war das nicht kredit
fürs studium top abschluss ein promotion
angebot des konzerns siemens sie schlug
es aus und rannte lange mit der frage wo
setzt sie ihr talent sinn von 1
dann die antwort sie gründet das
sozialunternehmen rock your life
ein studierender begleitet ein schüler
meistens aus der haupt- oder realschule
zwei jahre lang und die arbeiten beide
an ihren zielen an ihren träumen und an
ihrem potenzial rock your life heißt im
prinzip beweg dein leben komm hoch
gelobt übernimmt verantwortung so die
idee soll ein brückenschlag seien
zwischen zweien die sich eigentlich nie
begegnen wie claudia mich halt und julia
biermeier
die hauptschülerin konnte sich die
studentin von rock your life in einer
vorstellungsrunden in der schule
aussuchen
jetzt geht die studentin mit ihr in die
bibliothek hilft beim lernen eine
begleitung bis zum berufseinstieg denn
für hauptschüler ist es in deutschland
besonders schwer an eine gute ausbildung
zukommen als coach in dem sinne dass
sich ja einfach anstöße gibt und so
sagte claudia das doch mal wird das
reden oder einfach ein bisschen mehr zu
zeigen und ihr so ein bisschen die
schäfer vielen sachen zu nehmen gerade
eben vor büchern
ich weiß selbst wenn meine mama nicht
immer mir ein buch hingelegt hatte und
mir gelesen hatte da hätte ich auch
nicht eingefangen und kann es auch nicht
so cool ein honorar zahlt die sozial
unternehmerin dafür nicht elisabeth
hanke und ihren zwei mitgründern geht es
um gesellschaftliches engagement auch
oder gerade von unternehmen noch
finanziert sich rock your life nur von
spenden 500.000 euro haben sie
eingesammelt
doch das soll sich ändern was von dem
was wir schon wissen was wir gut können
wird dann gebraucht auf dem markt und
wer brauch ist und wer es auch bereit
dafür geld zu bezahlen also wirklich zu
gucken was können wir noch weiter
anbieten und dann welche services können
wir noch an den an den markt bringen und
dann auch den gemeinnützigen part immer
zum teil refinanzieren zu können
ausbauen wachsen aus einem kleinen
gemeinnützigen start up ein ganzes
bildungsunternehmen hochziehen
das ist ihr ziel neben den studenten
sollen künftig mehr unternehmer mit von
der partie sein
manager die praktika anbieten und
hauptschüler coachen
an visionen mangelt es ihr nicht wir
haben jetzt netzwerk an 2500 jungen
menschen ganz verteilt in deutschland
und die einen sich quasi und der dieser
idee bildungsgerechtigkeit stärker
herzustellen über brückenbau zwischen
studenten und schülern und dass es so
schön einfach zusehen wie ganz viele
junge leute wenn sie den raum bekommen
aktiv werden und mitgestalten und also
das will ich nicht aufgeben weil das
ganz ganz einfach schön
eine ganz andere karriere einzuschlagen
als die meisten uni absolventen
das hat mut gekostet aber die
unternehmerin würde diesen weg sofort
ein zweites mal gehen